um ihr nun live zugeschaltet axel
heimken denken sie tauchen seit 20
jahren bereits mit heim haben über 1500
tauchgänge hinter sich viele haie also
schon in der natur erlebt und wissen wie
diese tiere ticken was genau muss da vor
der küste von kalifornien passiert sein
dass ben kelly totgebissen wurde
also ich halte das ganze für nach lage
und sich der der nachrichten die bis
jetzt durchgekommen sind für einen
tragischen unfall
mein mitgefühl vor allen dingen mit dem
opfer mit dem server des eine situation
die nicht alltäglich ist
neuer angriff der zu einem zum tod führt
hat man ja gesehen 2004 das letzte mal
ich denke das ist eine verkettung von
von von umständen irgendwie die dazu
geführt haben
da ist viel pech dabei da ist viel glück
dabei und letztlich vermeiden kann man
sowas ali ganz ausschließen kann man es
auch nie ganz wie es genau dazu gekommen
ist kann man eigentlich auch nur
mutmaßen
gibt es denn etwas was man als surfer
machen kann oder generell wenn man im
wasser ist unser freier trifft etwas wie
man sich davor schützen kann man hört
oft einen schlag auf die nase auf das
maul soll helfen stimmt das auf keinen
fall also das tier niemals schlagen das
tier niemals provozieren
das kann dazu führen dass dann ein angst
bis kommt dass dann eine abwehrreaktion
kommt der beste tipp ist eigentlich
immer wirklich ruhe bewahren keine
geräusche machen keinen krach machen
sich einigermaßen senkrecht im wasser
auszurichten nicht parallel zur
wasseroberfläche und versuchen
augenkontakt zu dem tier zu halten und
dabei ruhig zu bleiben ich weiß das ist
nicht so ganz einfach das ist teilweise
große tiere das sind respekt einflößen
tirol sind raubtiere
der einzige schutz davor ist nicht ins
wasser zu gehen was in diesem fall ja
auch nicht machbar ist wenn man s surfen
will aber ruhe bewahren ist glaube ich
das mittel der stunde ich war
vergangenes jahr beispielsweise auch in
san francisco surfen viele der surfer
dort benutzten als ließ also als die
leine zwischen dem board und ihrem fuß
eine die elektrische schocks signale
abgibt um haie abzuwehren ist das etwas
was zumindest zu teilen helfen kann
also es hat im laufe der geschichte ja
schon viele versuche gegeben
der hai angriffe abzuwehren teilweise
vom militär entwickelt es gab aber es
gab verschiedene chemikalien die an der
ins wasser gelassen worden es gibt
heiner an bestimmten küsten die auch
unter strom gesetzt werden ich zu
bezweifeln
es ist meines wissens nach und ich
glaube da spreche ich auch schon viele
viele kollegen von von mir und auch
viele forscher ist es nach wie vor noch
nicht ist noch nicht das allheilmittel
die wunderwaffe erfunden die jeglichen
hai-angriff ausschließt jetzt habe ich
ja schon seit sie tauchen seit 20 jahren
mit diesen tieren haben sie dann angst
oder sind sie selber auch schon eine
brenzlige situationen gekommen
angst nicht nein ich glaube man sollte
respekt haben es ist nach wie vor die
natur in der man sich bewegt man sollte
sich immer bewusst sein dass es
raubtiere sind
ich glaube jeder der mal die persönliche
erfahrung macht in solchen tieren in
ihrer natürlichen umgebung zu sein zu
tauchen
der wird feststellen dass das
angstgefühl eigentlich abgelöst wird
durch durch eine art respektvolle
faszination und auch da geht man die
erfahrung machen dass diese tiere
eigentlich erst sind das ist keine keine
angreifenden gefährlichen was weiß ich
tiere sind die blutrünstig was auch
immer alle auf alles ein beißen das im
wasser ist das gegenteil ist der fall
von daher nein angst nicht respekt
sollte man in jedem fall haben und
letztlich als mensch begibt man sich in
deren territorium deren umgebung und es
zeigt ja auch die anzahl der eingriffe
weltweit
es sind so viele menschen die ins wasser
gehen so viele menschen die schwimmen
tauchen baden in gebieten wo haie sind
wenn der mensch nötig
dem beuteschema eines hai entsprechen
würde dann gäbe es viel mehr opfer das
ist nicht der fall
für diese analyse zu dem tragischen
unglück das sich in kalifornien jetzt
abgesplittert dankeschön